Hello, everybody. My
name is Ryan Johnson,
and I'm a data science
adviser here at Posit,
and welcome to this
month's enterprise community meetup,
where we'll discuss another end
to end data science workflow
using Posit Team. And just as
a reminder, this is a recurring
event that occurs on the last
Wednesday of every month,
and we hope it'll serve as
a good primer for those that are
brand new to Posit Team,
but also help current Posit Team
users become more
familiar with our tools.
Now with the holiday
season upon us,
there is no better way
to express your holiday spirit
than by sharing the gift
of a beautifully crafted,
organized data science
workflow. So with that in mind,
and during today's demo,
we're gonna discuss tools
and techniques within Posit's tool
chain specifically designed for
sharing and collaborating with others.
So to kick things off,
I first wanna make sure
everyone here has a solid high
level understanding
of Posit team.
So Posit Team,
it's a bundled offering of
our three professional tools.
We have Posit Workbench,
Posit Connect,
and Posit Package Manager.
And if we start right up here
at the top with your data
scientists, they're going
to be creating insights.
So writing code within
Posit Workbench.
And they can choose
whichever IDE they want.
It can be our studio,
JupyterLab, Jupyter notebook,
or VS code.
And they can also program
in whatever language they want.
So for your r developers,
maybe they're creating things
like shiny applications or r
markdown or quarto documents.
And for your Python developers,
maybe they're creating
Jupyter notebook. Or fast API,
streamlit, shiny, vetiver,
then the list goes on.
But it doesn't do your
developers any good if they
can't share this content with the
people that need to see it,
and that's the whole
purpose of Posit Connect.
This is our professional
publishing platform.
So it gives a home for
all this content your data scientists
are creating so that they can
easily share them with the
people that need to see them.
And that could be, you know,
coworkers. It could be a
decision makers at your company,
or maybe you just wanna
share it with friends and family.
And then our last tool
is Posit package manager,
which does exactly
as this name implies.
It helps control all those
amazing open source r and
Python packages your team uses.
It also gives a home to any
internally developed
R and Python packages.
We also just released,
some really cool new features
within package manager so you
can actually control access over
which packages your team can use.
Now, before we get
into the actual demo,
I wanna take a moment
to talk about, you know,
why does Posit care so
much about open source data science?
And the list I'm gonna present
is not an exhaustive list,
but I did want to highlight
a few points why Posit is so
invested in open source data
science especially in the
context of sharing
and collaborating.
First, open source data
science is free. Meaning,
if you want to share
your workflow with someone else,
there is no requirement
to purchase any software.
All the components needed to run
the workflow are completely free of charge.
Second, open source data
science, it promotes transparency.
Now when you share a
workflow with someone,
they will know everything,
and I mean everything that
went into your analyses because they
have access to
your source code.
There's no proprietary or black
box analyses that are hidden
from your collaborators.
And finally, open source data
science allows teams to easily
collaborate with
specific people,
but also with the greater
data science community.
I'm sure many folks listening
to this webinar right now have
likely had a data science
question and posted it to a
public forum and hopefully got
a response from the community.
This is the type of data
science learning and support
that Posit wants to encourage.
So what options exist today?
To collaborate and share content
using Posit's tools.
Well, the first way is to
share your source code,
and that's where version
control comes into play.
So many of the tools that
we create here at Posit,
including the various IDEs
included in Posit Workbench
they have integrations, to
make working with version control,
including get a breeze.
Virging control and repository
hosting like GitHub or maybe
your team uses Bitbucket are
some of the most important
tools for data
science collaboration.
We also have some cool features
built into Posit team that can
assist with data
science collaboration,
including project sharing
and get back deployment.
So project sharing,
this is a feature in Posit
Workbench and allows for users
to work together on
RStudio projects.
You can even do a
live code editing with this feature,
which we'll demonstrate
a little bit later on.
Finally,
we'll finish our workflow
today by demonstrating git back
deployment within
Posit Connect,
which can be used to
directly deploy content to Posit Connect
from a Git repository.
So to go over today's workflow,
we are first going to start
by creating a new repository on
GitHub, which will be the
home base, so to speak,
for our collaborative
data science project.
We'll then pull the repository into
Posit Workbench as an RStudio project.
For this simple workflow,
we're gonna be creating
a shiny application in R,
and we'll show you how
more than one user can collaborate
on the same piece of code using
version control as well as project sharing.
And I'll be showing version
control features in both RStudio,
as well as visual studio code
running within Workbench.
Finally,
we'll show you how to publish
the collaborative shiny
application hosted on GitHub
using get back deployment.
So to kick off this workflow,
here I am within
my GitHub homepage,
And I'm gonna start a
brand new repository.
So in the top right
corner, you'll see this green new
button. We'll go ahead
and click on this.
I'm gonna choose
me as the owner,
and I'm just gonna give this
repository a random name.
I'll just call it test
repo one two three.
For the description, I'll
just say this is a test repo.
We'll make this public, and I'll
go ahead and add or read me.
And then I'll hit
create repository.
So here's the current
state of repository.
It's pretty bare bones.
The only thing you'll see
inside of it is that read me
file. And that's
pretty much it.
But what I wanna do next
is I'm gonna take this repository I
just created, and I'm gonna
pull it into Posit Workbench as
an rstudio project.
And to do that,
the first thing I need to do
is just grab the URL for this
GitHub repository.
Let me navigate over
to Posit Workbench.
And if this is the
first time you're seeing Posit Workbench,
this is the home screen
when you first log in.
And I'm signed in in this
instance as publisher one.
And I'm just gonna open up a
brand new session by clicking right here.
You can see the four separate
IDEs that Posit Workbench
currently supports.
And for right now, we're
just gonna live within RStudio Pro.
And I'll go ahead and
kick on the session.
So here we are within the
RStudio IDE. On the left hand
side, we have our console,
in the top right corner,
we have our environment pane,
and in the bottom corner,
you can see our file directory.
So I'm gonna go ahead and pull
in a GitHub repository as an RStudio project.
And to do that,
there's actually a few
different ways you can create a
project in RStudio,
but my preference is to go
in the top right corner.
You can see project none I'm gonna
click on this and select new project.
And when you click
on that option,
you'll get this pop up menu
to select how you want to create
your project. You can
create a new directory,
which is like creating a new
file on your desktop or your
computer, for example,
You can also create a
project in an existing directory if
that file already
exists on your computer,
or you can pull in a project
from version control.
And this is the
option I want to use.
Since we're using git and
GitHub, I'm gonna select a git,
and then I'll paste in the URL
for my repository.
We'll just leave the name
as test repo one two three,
and I'm gonna place it in
my home directory of my project,
which is represented
by this tilde.
And then I'm gonna use our
version four point three point
two for this analysis.
And just a cool feature
of Posit Workbench is you can
actually choose from
different r versions,
and you can have as many
r and Python versions as you want
installed on your
server. And with that,
we'll hit create project.
Every time you
create a new project,
it'll always open up a
new RStudio session. So here we
are. And if you look in
the top right corner,
you can see now we're in
the test repo one two three project.
So now that we have
this project created,
we first want to
create something,
because right now it's
just a bare bones project.
And so I'm gonna create
a shiny application.
Now within the r studio IDE,
there's actually one that comes
built into the RStudio IDE.
So if you click in the
top left corner up here,
you'll see shiny web app.
So I'm gonna use this as
kind of like a scaffolding,
but I'm actually gonna bring
in a custom application that our
team has created.
So I'm gonna call
this test app,
and I'll just leave
it as at test app.
This is gonna be a
single file app dot r,
and I'm gonna place it
within our project's directory which
again we called test repo one
two three, and I'll hit create.
So you'll notice down here
in the file directory,
and I can make my screen
a little bit bigger here.
And by file directory right
here, you can see test app.
That's the directory
we just created.
And inside of it is the single
file, the app dot r file,
is what you're seeing now in
the top left corner of the
rstudio IDE.
This is your source pane.
Now if you're not
familiar with shiny,
Shiny is just a way for you
to create interactive web
applications using R code.
You can also do it
in Python as well.
Now I mentioned before that
this is like a placeholder application,
that you can run by
clicking this little run application
button, and you can see
here's an example shiny application.
But let's go ahead.
I'm gonna pop in some code
for a little bit more of a
interesting shiny application.
I'm gonna go ahead and
delete all this placeholder information,
and I'm gonna copy in some
code over here on my screen,
and I'm gonna paste it in.
Alright. So this is a
slightly longer application,
but it's still not too long.
It's less than a
hundred lines of code.
But it's gonna incorporate some
really cool new features of
Shiny that we're really excited
about including this bslib package,
which is really great for
creating really nice looking
shiny applications
and dashboards.
So let's go ahead and run this
application and explore it a little bit.
So you can actually see right
here I'm actually missing a package.
And this is actually a pretty cool
little tangent we can go on here.
I need to actually install
this icon for this application to
work. So when I click install,
I'm gonna just go ahead and
hit this install button.
We're gonna get this
jobs tab that opens up,
and it's gonna go really
fast. I'm actually using Posit
package manager to install this
package. As a pre built binary.
So it's only gonna take a
couple seconds, and boom, it's
done. So now we can try
running the application,
and here we go.
Alright. So here's this shiny
application, again, using
BSLib. And what it's looking at
is a dataset called palmer penguins,
and Some of you may have
heard of this dataset before.
It's a really popular,
dataset for just
ex doing, you know,
exploratory data analysis
but it's actually real data,
which is why I like it so much.
And you can see we get
some nice value cards along the top
that summarizes some
information about these various
penguins. And then you could
see some charts in here,
like the Bill length,
Bill depth, Bill mass,
separated by either
species, island,
or if it's a male
or female penguin.
Just some cool
features of BSlib,
we can click on these
individual cards and expand
them so you can see the
plot in more detail.
So this is gonna be the shiny
application that we're gonna work on today.
Alright. So the first feature
that I wanna go over within
Posit's tools for sharing and collaborating
is going to be project sharing.
Let's say, for example,
that you wanna call up
your coworker someone on the other
side of the world,
and you want to have them help
you out when writing this shiny application.
Now if anyone here is familiar
with, like, Google Docs, for example,
and you know when two people
are working on the same Google
doc at the exact same time,
you can actually see their cursor
and you can see them typing live.
And that's a lot of
the same functionality that you'll get
with project sharing within
Posit Workbench and these
RStudio projects.
So I'm gonna go ahead
and share this project,
this test repo one two
three project with another user on
this instance of
Posit work branch.
So I'm first gonna click the name
of the project in the top right corner,
and you're gonna see
this option to share project.
So in this pop up window,
we can choose who we want to
share this project with.
So I mentioned before
that on this instance,
I'm currently log
in as publisher one.
Let's go ahead and share
it with publisher two.
So I'll start typing
out publisher two.
This is typically gonna be
tied into your authentication,
within your team. So I'll
select publisher two and select
add. And there we go.
We've now just shared
this project with Publisher two.
So now we kinda have to use
our imagination a little bit,
and I'm gonna switch roles into
Publisher two. And so I'm gonna
bring on another screen here, and
I'm gonna use the, kind of,
the dark format of Posit
Workbench, because I'm here
logged in as Publisher two.
And here on the home
screen of Posit Workbench,
you can see over here
on the right hand side,
there's the test repo one
two three you'll see the little
folder icon with the
arrow inside of it.
That indicates a project that has
been shared with me as publisher two.
And I can click right here
to jump right into that project.
Alright. So here I am
within that project,
test repo one two three.
And the first thing you'll notice
up here in the top is
this little p that
stands for publisher one.
So if I want to follow
publisher one's cursor, all I
need to do is click on this
box right here. And you can see
opens up this icon or
the window right here with the
shiny application that we
were working on previously.
And then if I switch back
over to publisher one.
You can see that little PFP up
up here that stands for publisher two.
And let's go ahead and
follow their cursor as well.
So now I'm gonna try
my best to demonstrate this functionality.
So here in the background,
we have publisher one,
and in the foreground,
we have publisher two.
And if I start typing here,
you'll notice I'll just make
some comments here that this
edit was made by publisher two.
And then if I wanted to,
conversely, I can come back
here, and I'll make another
edit as publisher one,
and you can see how that's
reflected right here,
in the other window. So again, this
is a great option for live collaboration.
So there's a piece of source
code that you wanna work on at
the exact same time
with somebody else,
then you should
really check out,
project sharing from
within Posit Workbench.
Now while project sharing is
an extremely powerful tool, we'd
certainly advocate for the
use of version control and
repository hosting services
like GitHub, Bitbucket, GitLab,
for your sharing of
data science projects.
What I'm gonna do now,
within this session, again,
here logged in
as publisher one,
I'm gonna take all of
this source code that we've been
working on, including
the shiny application.
I'm gonna save it here
locally within Posit Workbench and show
you how we can push
these changes up to that GitHub
repository that we
previously connected to.
So the first thing I'm going
to do is save this shiny application.
You can see here it's in
this red text with little asterisk.
That lets me know that's
not currently saved.
I'm gonna go ahead and hit
the floppy disk symbol right here.
It's gonna save my file.
And now to show some of
the git integrations,
If you look over here in
the top right hand side,
there's a tab up here in
the top right called git.
And this is gonna show you
all the git integrations within the
RStudio IDE.
And currently, we see a lot
of question marks right now. So
the first file is
this git ignore file.
This was actually added by
RStudio created this project,
as well as this test repo
one two three dot r project file,
which is always created in the
home directory of a project in
r studio project.
And then we also have
this test app directory.
So if I come back to
my project's directory,
which is right here,
And inside of it is going to
be that shiny application.
Now currently, we see
all these question marks,
and that's because git version
control, it sees these files,
but doesn't really know
what to do with them.
Should it ignore them,
should it track them?
But we want to go ahead
and have git track these files so
that we can push
them up to GitHub.
So to kick off that process,
the first thing we're going to
do is stage all these files.
And I like to think of it
just like staging for a play.
So while the curtains
are still closed,
you wanna make sure everything's
set up in the right place.
It's staged and ready to go
for when those curtains open.
So let's go ahead and
stage these three objects.
So I'll click the bottom
one, the middle one,
and the top one right here.
So once we have
these all staged,
we're gonna go ahead and make
a local commit to version control.
And if you see right
here, this toolbar,
it provides a lot of helpful,
operations for git, right
here within the RStudio IDE.
So you don't necessarily have
to use the terminal or the
command line. So I'm gonna
select this commit box,
and it's gonna open up a
window here, which I'm gonna adjust.
And let's just go ahead
and explore this for a second.
So over here in the
top left corner,
this is the same window that
we were seeing within the rstudio
IDE, the three files,
And now since they're staged,
you can see this little a.
That corresponds
to being added.
So these have been added
to version control. They're
staged. They're ready to go.
And down here at the
bottom, you can see any differences.
Now every single one of these
files is completely new to
version control, which is why
everything's showing up in
green. But if you were to
make any edits or remove any lines,
you might see some red,
lines in here as well
corresponding to things that were deleted.
So if you're happy with
all these changes, which we are,
we have this new shiny
application that we worked on
collaboratively
with Publisher two,
let's go ahead and commit
this locally to version control.
We have to add a
commit message here.
Now this is a bit of
an art form because you wanna make
these commit messages
as informative as possible,
but also pretty short. So
I'm just gonna say create
shiny app. And that's pretty
much it. I'll hit commit.
You'll see this pop up window,
which shows you some of the
git commands that were running the
background, along
with its output.
So if I close this window,
you can now see the Git
window over here is now empty,
but we see this
little kind of information, flag,
letting us know that our branch is
ahead of origin main by one commit.
And what that is basically
telling us is that our GitHub
repository hosted up in GitHub,
we are actually one commit
ahead of what's on GitHub.
So if we're ready to push
these changes up to our GitHub repository,
we can again use the rstudio
IDE to help us out here by
simply clicking
this push button.
Now you may have to set up
your git and GitHub credentials
beforehand. This is something
I did before this workshop.
Just to make sure that my instance
of our studio here can talk to,
GitHub and that it knows who
I am and I have the credentials
to make these pushes.
So now that we've
pushed those changes,
let me switch back over
to my GitHub repository,
and let me refresh my page.
And so here's the current
state of our GitHub repository.
We have that read me
file, which we originally created.
Here's that R Proj and
git ignore files that our studio
automatically added for us,
and here's our test app.
Here's that shiny
application we're working on.
I can click into it.
Click on the app dot r
file and see all the code.
So now that we have the
shiny application on GitHub,
it is prying for collaboration.
So let's say, for example, that
publisher two wanted to pull in
this GitHub repository and do
some changes to their shiny application,
which we're gonna
demonstrate right now.
So here's the current state
again of our GitHub repository.
Let me go ahead
and regrab the URL,
and then I'm gonna
drag in publisher two.
Alright.
I'll try to make my screen
a little bit nicer to see here.
Alright.
So I want to make some
changes to that shiny application as
publisher two. Okay. Because,
again, I'm a collaborator.
I wanna work alongside
publisher one to develop a
shiny application.
Now, we could do
this in RStudio,
but let me just go ahead
and show you how someone might do
it within Visual Studio
Code running within Posit Workbench.
I'm gonna open up another
session because you can have
multiple sessions running
within Posit Workbench,
and I'm gonna select Visual
Studio code and hit start session.
Alright. So here we are
within visual studio code,
and it's pretty much
a blank environment.
If I click on my file
explorer over here,
it's letting me know No
folder has been opened.
And if we look along
the left hand side,
you'll notice there's actually
a source control icon.
So we can click on this
And let's go ahead and clone in
that repository that I
just copied the URL for.
So I'll click clone repository
and paste in the URL.
And I'm gonna place it
right here in my home directory.
Let's go ahead and open it up.
And now you can see we're
within that test repo one two
three, and here's my test app
with that app dot r file being
shown here. And again, this
is all running within VS Code.
So let's say again,
as publisher two,
I wanna make some changes.
I'm not gonna make any
dramatic changes here.
I'm just gonna scroll down
to, let's see, our line twenty
nine. You can see here's
the title of this dashboard,
penguin's dashboard.
Let's make that a little
bit more informative. Let's say Palmer
penguins dashboard
because that's the,
the dataset that
we're gonna be using.
We're just gonna add
Palmer here. I'll hit save.
You'll notice there's this little
one icon over here in
the source control. So let's
go ahead and click on that.
And you'll notice that there's
been a change here within this
app dot r file.
So let's go through some of the
same steps we just did within rstudio.
So the first thing we need to
do is we want to stage this
change, and we can do that
by clicking this little plus icon.
And once it's been staged, we
want to add a commit message.
And I'm just going to make
it nice, short, and sweet.
So it's a change app title.
And we'll hit commit.
And once those changes have
been committed, again, locally,
here within VS code
running on Posit workbench,
we can then push those changes
up to GitHub. So again,
we can just click
on the sync changes,
and that should push everything
up to our GitHub repository.
Alright. So now with that's
done, let me switch back over
to my GitHub repository.
And I'll refresh my page.
Let's just go into application and
make sure that change is there.
So we'll scroll down here,
and now you can see on
line twenty nine Palmer penguins dashboard.
Now I'm gonna switch back
over to publisher one here.
Because again, now I have
a change in my GitHub repository
that's not currently reflected within my
local code here as publisher one.
You can still see title
is the old Just penguin's dashboard.
So now would be a great time
to pull in those changes from that
GitHub repository, those
changes made by Publisher two.
And to do that again within
the rstudio IDE, we have nice easy
features to do this. We
already pushed before.
Let's go ahead and pull.
And once we do that,
you can see all the output
here from running the pull command.
And now if we scroll down
in our source code here,
palmer has been added
to the title. So again,
that's how you can
work collaboratively,
with version control using
whatever IDEs you want with
whomever you want.
Okay. So we've shown you a
few different things now, which are,
helpful for collaborating and sharing
data science workflows with others.
But now we have this great
shiny application over here on
the left hand side.
It's been worked on by
two separate developers.
And ultimately, we want to
be able to share this application
with whoever needs to see it.
And that's where Posit
Connect comes into play.
So we're gonna go ahead and
show you how to publish this
application to Posit Connect.
Now here within
the RStudio IDE,
you can actually implement something
known as push button deployment.
And we showed this in some
of our previous workflows.
Here's that little blue icon
on the top of your screen,
which you can easily
push, and I could manually
publish this to Posit Connect
And this is a great option,
especially if you just want
to quickly share an application
with somebody or any piece of
content that can be hosted on Connect.
However,
if I publish this to connect
and then I come back to my
source code and
I make a change,
I'm going to have to
click the button again and republish.
So it's a bit of
a manual process.
So what we're gonna show
you here is something called
git-backed deployment.
So instead of publishing it
directly from the rstudio IDE,
we're actually just gonna
have Posit Connect look at our
GitHub repository.
And if it ever detects a
change in a GitHub repository,
so commit in that
GitHub repository,
it can automatically
rebuild that content for us.
So to kick off the get
back deployment process,
we have a few things we
need to do to get started.
So I'm gonna go ahead and just clear
my console down here in the bottom left.
And I want to go
into the directory that houses the
content that we ultimately want
to be published on Connect.
So here within that
test app directory,
You can see we just have
the single app.R file.
And I'm actually gonna set this
as my working directory just to
make things a
little bit simpler.
Now when we publish this
application to Posit Connect,
Posit Connect needs to
know some information about my
current working environment, such
as what packages am I
using? What versions
of those packages?
What are version am I using?
So that information is needed by
connect so that it can, you know,
just make sure it runs
this application correctly without any issues.
Now for push button deployment,
this little blue button,
a lot of that's
done automatically,
but if we're gonna use
git-back deployment,
we just need to provide that information
and it's super easy to do it.
So from within the directory of
the content you want to publish,
all you need to do is
run from the rsconnect package there's a
function called writeManifest.
That's it. I'll hit enter.
It's gonna capture some of
my dependencies using another
really great package called
renv and then it generates this
manifest dot JSON file.
I can click into it, and we
can just take a quick peek,
and it's pretty noisy.
There's a lot of
great information in here that
connect can easily read,
but for the most part,
it's just information about packages
in my environment and, like,
what versions of those packages
and where I obtained them from.
All the information connect
needs to replicate my
environment exactly as it is
right here within Posit workbench.
So now that we've
created this file,
we wanna make sure that we
also include this file within our
GitHub repository.
So let's go ahead and just
show you that workflow one more
time. So we have this manifest
dot JSON file that's been
added, within my git repository
or within version control.
Let's go ahead and stage
it. I'm going to commit it,
and we'll just make a quick
message here. Of add manifest file,
and then we'll commit
that up to GitHub.
So if I come back to
my GitHub repository,
we click on test app. We
need a refresh here.
Since now I've done something
wrong here. Oh, yeah.
I gotta gotta push
it, obviously.
So let's go ahead
and push that.
There we go. So I committed
it, and then I had to push it.
Now if I refresh my
page, we have the app,
and we have the manifest
file right alongside of it.
So let's go ahead and take
this app application on my GitHub
repository and publish it
directly from this GitHub repository.
So I'm gonna regrab the
URL for the third time.
And I'm gonna switch over to
Posit Connect here in this demo environment.
So this is the home
screen of Posit Connect.
Just some example content that
we have here just to explore
all the various pieces of
content you can currently host
on Posit Connect.
But in the very top here,
you'll see this publish drop
down, and I'm gonna
select import from git.
I'm gonna paste in the URL,
and also hit click next.
And it's gonna ask me what
branch I want to publish from.
Now our GitHub repository
just has a single branch.
It's that main branch,
but there's actually a pretty
cool workflow here where you
can have multiple versions
of a single piece of content
published on
different branches.
So maybe you have like a
production version on the main branch,
but maybe you have a
development version on some
other you can actually publish
two pieces of content from the
same GitHub repository
from different branches.
But we just have one branch
that's main, so we'll select next.
And then it's gonna
look for directories
where you can find
that manifest dot JSON file.
So these are
deployable directories.
And it found one inside
that test app directory,
and all we have to do
is give our application a name. I'll
say, test, app. We'll just
keep it nice and simple.
And then we'll hit
deploy content.
So at this point,
Posit Connect is reading in
that manifest file and just
making sure it can
replicate my environment.
And once it's done, we
can click open content,
and we'll just give it a
few seconds to boot up.
Alright.
So here is that shiny
application that we've been working on,
and you can actually see
the title here reflects that change
that publisher two made
palmer, and it looks,
and it behaves just like it did
when it was running within Posit Workbench.
Now to demonstrate how powerful
Git-backed deployment is,
so this application is now
linked to that GitHub repository.
And if anyone,
anyone I'm collaborating with
makes a change to the main
branch on the
GitHub repository,
it'll automatically be
reflected here within deployed
content on Posit Connect.
So it'll automatically stay updated.
So let me actually go ahead
and show you that workflow quick.
I'm gonna come back here to
my environment publisher one,
but anyone can do this.
Publisher two or anyone else
that's working on this GitHub
repository and has access
to that main branch.
Let's go ahead and make
another change to the title.
So I have Palmer
penguins dashboard,
and I'm just gonna add a dash
Oh, let's just I'm gonna add
a smiley face. There we go.
Kinda silly, but another
change. We'll hit save.
Now you can see in the git
tab, we have a modified this file.
So let's go ahead and stage
it. I'm going to commit it locally,
and I'll say add
smiley face. To title.
And then we'll
commit this locally,
and then push it up to GitHub.
So now if I switch back over
to my GitHub repository,
let's just check the
application and make sure that
change is reflected.
Alright.
So you can see the smiley
face right here on line twenty nine.
Now I'm gonna switch back
over to Posit Connect.
I'm gonna refresh my page here.
And you'll notice that the
smiley face isn't yet there.
That's because this piece
of content, usually by default,
is only gonna
check every, like,
fifteen minutes to see if there's
a change to that github repository.
So we could just hang out
here for fifteen minutes and wait
for that change to, take effect.
And this is a time frame that
can be modified by your system administrators,
but we can actually just
manually kick off that check.
So if I go to my info tab here,
scroll down, check
for updates from,
periodically for tht
github repository,
or I can just have it
manually check and click update now.
Let's go ahead and
click this button.
So it sees says changes
were found in the git repository,
so it automatically
rebuilds it. Hit okay.
And now you can see the smiley
face reflected here in our
final, shiny
application. So again,
git-backed deployment
is a fantastic way for,
collaborating with others and also
having a piece of content
hosted on Connect that's
automatically updated anytime
someone makes a change to
that branch on the GitHub repository.
And that wraps up our last
Posit Team workflow of twenty twenty three.
And I really hope you all found
today's session helpful for
collaborative data science.
Now usually for these sessions,
we'd have a live question
and answer right afterwards.
But just given the time of the
year and the fact that a lot of
people are out of the office,
we instead wanted to provide
you with another way to ask
questions. So on the screen here
will be a link to a forum
on Posit's Community page,
which we'd welcome any
questions about today's content.
Finally, as a reminder,
all of these Posit Team demos
are recorded and publicly
available, which you
can view on YouTube.
We hope you have a
great holiday season,
and we look forward to seeing
you again for our next workflow
in twenty twenty four.